panel madeleine brémond et stéphanie
grammond chantal hébert bonsoir pourtant
un petit mot sur la frontière
j'ai pas souvent entendu monsieur
charest doit avant septembre ça serait
étonnant il ya des pressions
contradictoires compliquer le jeu
politique chantal je commençais avec
vous je posais la question à monsieur
charest je vous la pose est ce que parce
que monsieur trudeau a été très très
critiqué au début surtout de cette
question de frontières et de voyages là
il veut être plus prudent que moi
j'entends non je ne crois pas que ce
soit la baisse pas de raison je pense
que ç'a beaucoup à voir avec
l'opposition d'un certain nombre de
premier ministre à premier titre le
premier ministre l'ontario john ford et
une joute politique entre ces deux
gouvernements dans un premier temps et
dans un deuxième temps sur une question
pratique aux pratiques avant d'ouvrir la
frontière aux américains il faudrait
quand même d'ouvrir le chantier canada
ça me semble la première étape
essentielle j'ai entendu votre entrevue
avec jean charest pour l'essentiel ses
responsables à ce qu'on entend à ottawa
stéphanie parce que la pression monte
aux cieux ou sur des barges en a qui
veulent savoir quand est-ce qu'on sera
prêt et ici aussi
moi je pense qu'effectivement il vaut
mieux être prudent biologique on veut
pas se retrouver aller trop vite peut
être obligé de reculer
mais de notre côté peut-être que le
gouvernement fédéral pourrait s'inspirer
de ce qui s'est fait dans les provinces
avec des plans de déconfinement ou mais
nos cartes sur la table qui ont du bon
alors voici où est ce qu'on s'en va
parce que c'est vrai que dans le milieu
des affaires un peu partout des gens qui
ont des maisons et de l'autre côté de la
frontière
ça commence à ça commence à devenir pour
un simple les gens veulent avoir des
réponses donc c'est peut-être une façon
de s'en sortir puis aussi on peut y
aller graduelle
parce que des situations comme des gens
qui sont double vacciner et qui sont
obligés de se soumettre à toutes les
règles même le comité d'experts a
souligné l'incohérence de tout ça
peut-être qu'on peut commencer par
appliquer une certaine forme ne pense
pas vaccinale pour c'est pour ces gens
là mais au moins ces gouvernements nous
disait on est ensemble ça serait je
pense une bonne idée un comité d'experts
madeleine qui avait conseillé que le
confinement dans un hôtel à 14 jours
était pas à quelques jours + 4 jours à
la maison n'était pas nécessairement une
bonne chose tout le temps qu'il fallait
plus souple en fait que c'était pas une
bonne chose tout court parce que la
règle et est facilement contournable des
gens pouvaient par exemple payer une
amende plutôt que d'aller à l'hôtel est
payé 2000 $ pour un séjour de trois
jours
mais ce qu'on entend c'est que il ya
toute une couche de mesures de
protection pour les frontières il ya
cette quarantaine à l'hôtel on la
continue à la maison il ya trois tests à
faire avant de partir à l'arrivée un dix
jours plus tard lorsqu'on est en train
de faire la quarantaine à la maison donc
ce que j'entends c'est que on devrait
avoir des signaux bientôt à savoir que
si certaines cibles qui sont respectés
je pense par exemple à des sites de
vaccination on pourrait dire telle
catégorie de personnes n'auraient plus à
se soumettre à telle mesure par exemple
peut-être la quarantaine à l'hôtel mais
j'ai pas les détails je ne sais pas par
exemple quelle catégorie de personnes
pourront être exemptés de quelle mesure
mais effectivement la pression va
devenir de plus en plus propres profonde
importance et c'est pas vrai que du jour
au lendemain le gouvernement va vouloir
tout annuler tout enlever c'est sûr que
ce sera progressif
scade un peu le gouvernement c'est que
comme monsieur faut mener sa bataille là
dessus en tête tous les malheurs qui se
sont abattus sur l'ontario sont venues
de la frontière et donc c'est la faute
de justin trudeau
c'est encore un énorme pour des
conservateurs à la chambre des communes
de monter aux barricades pour dire
pourquoi vous oubliez pas de frontières
c'est à peupler la meilleure carte dans
le jeu du gouvernement mais c'est sûr
que d'ici
la fin de l'été et même avant ça il va y
avoir des allègements bon les deux mike
on apprend donc ce matin le blosne nous
apprend tractations du l'ambassadeur
canadien à pékin qui est allé rencontrer
entre autres l'ambassadeur chinois à
washington parce que les américains
c'est incontournable pour résoudre cette
équation là doivent jeter du lest un peu
sur man wan joue sinon on voit pas
comment ça peut se régler madeleine les
chinois sont claires même s'ils ne sont
pas claires sur le lien entre les deux
affaires le sont quand même ici les
américains ne bouge pas on voit pas tout
pour vous pourrez pour prévenir la
solution qu'est ce qui dérange gens les
chinois c'est que même moi joe et
finalement est détenu même s'il est très
bonnes conditions
au canada elle est au canada et elle
fait face à une demande d'extradition
des états unis
donc nous canadiens on est pris avec un
problème qui se déroule entre les états
unis et la chine
ce qu'on comprend c'est que finalement
s'il ya des tractations entre les
américains et la compagnie huawei pour
avoir un accord de réparation le canada
n'a rien à voir là dedans mais le canada
peut devenir finalement quelqu'un qui
encourage ce genre de négociation là ce
genre de tractations aulas et 6 par
exemple que dominic barton a pu faire
aux états unis entre autres aussi avec
l'ambassadrice du canada aux états unis
donc notre rôle où notre notre pouvoir
de négociation à nous canadiens est très
très très limité mais on peut du moins
encouragé puis dire que c'est très
important pour nous c'est fini
ouais c'est ça mais effectivement nous
on est on est vraiment dans une fâcheuse
position at l'armée les corses et puis
c'est difficile parce que personne ne
veut trop marcher sur la peinture d'un
côté bon et plus d'espoir avec joe biden
comme président des états unis qu'avec
donnant 30 mais ça reste que
département la justice aux états unis et
indépendant donc est-ce que jusqu'à quel
point il peut intervenir
et ça ça demande un tout petit peu de
créativité de côté de la maison blanche
et puis ici madame mais wenzhou
ça fait deux ans qu'elle dit qu'elle est
qu'elle est pas coupable
donc est ce qu est ce qu elle aurait
vraiment eu envie de changer son fusil
d'épaulé reconnaître un certain nombre
de choses c'est cesser des négociations
qui sont loin d'epinal puis un avion qui
le temps plein en chine peut-être
chantal en clair il faudrait que les
américains offrent quelque chose à la
chine que la chine voudrait davantage
que de continuer avec moi oui à
maintenir une innovation soit oui
effectivement c'est pas le canada que
quelque chose à mettre sur la table
ciqual pas non plus canada vis-à-vis de
la chine c'est que c'est vrai qu'on est
pas des grands joueurs dans cette partie
là et on s'est fait prendre dans
l'engrenage mais d'autres pharand loi
canadienne à la fin du processus il ya
une décision politique la parole du
ministère fédéral de la justice à savoir
si on dit oui ou non une demande
d'extradition en clair monsieur lâm et y
aurait le pouvoir de dire non aux
frappes au sol on s'entend relations
canado américaines etc
mais si l'on regarde en france passion
la perspective l'extérieur on prend
trois métiers mais se livre au jeu mais
maintenant je refuse d'accéder à la
demande d'extradition qui auraient été
les trouver légitime
le bureau canadien vous avez tout à fait
raison en fait c'est oui mais il ya des
gens qui ont fait pression qu'ils ancien
juge de la cour suprême on dire on
arrête il y aurait fallu qu'on fasse ça
parce que là il ya quand même deux vies
ok on va suivre ça 900 jours deux ans et
demi qui sont en jeu le procès alberta
chantal je commence avec vous référons
nous on va écouter
jason kenney et avancer sur la
péréquation
un petit extrait ensuite en anglais a
oui il dit le québec a tout eu dans
toute jours fâché en écoute ça ne
changera pas
l'application tout de suite parce que
nous nous pouvons nous n'avons pas le
pouvoir de le faire unilatéralement
mais ça va elle avait jusque jusqu'au
sommet les demandes essentielles de la
bataille pour une position plus juste en
fédérations
le québec a bloqué droit dans les faits
dit il un droit de veto en bloquant le
projet d'énergie est ce que voulait
amener le pétrole albertain vers les
marchés extérieurs alors chante elle et
elle a pris il faut dire aux gens
c'était la présentation de son
référendum sur la péréquation il les
reconnaît lui-même qui a pas de pouvoir
sur ça mais que ça va envoyer un message
fort à tahoua qu'est-ce que vous déco
des vins comme une montgolfière dû
remonter les tournages ce que je décode
c'est que jesse une canette un premier
en grande difficulté et que s'il est en
grande difficulté c'est parce qu'une
partie des gens qui ont voté pour lui ne
veulent plus rien savoir de son
leadership au même moment où on dévoile
cette question référendaire donc de son
propre aveu l'issue est déjà connue
parce que non on n'enlève pas la
pression de la constitution à moins que
que le nombre requis de province comme
pour le faire et ça a livre pas son
ancien partenaire pour réunifier la
droite brian jean qui était le chef du
parti wildrose disait il faut que duncan
et démissionne et les sondages dans le
moment montrent que s'il y avait des
élections en alberta
le npd rencontré un gouvernement
majoritaire
alors c'est leur fond dit monsieur
cannes et essaie de recréer une espèce
de trame narrative l'a amené au pouvoir
voilà je suis pas convaincu qu'il ya
aujourd'hui la crédibilité pour appuyer
cette trame narrative ou que même au
sein de la dgde province il yad'autres
premier ministre qui le regarde comme il
ya un an et demi en disant voilà un
leader à notre table de quelqu'un
d'influent c'est plutôt le contraire
c'est incroyable comme un an et demi les
shows des dents et la pandémie mai
prochain c'est fait des grands vents il
veut quand il veut reprojeter le même
film c'est ce qu'il l'avait amené la
pierre il était à l'époque populaire un
système de ses promesses électorales de
ce référendum là et puis c'est vrai que
effectivement les gens alberto sont une
frustration est réel puis un espèce de
sentiment d'aliénation comme quoi et ep
i pays payent et puis les ont jamais eu
de péréquation depuis 1964 alors bon
tous en lien au québec évidemment il ya
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de fausses
clés qui sont véhiculés à travers ça et
donc il faut comprendre que la
péréquation et sa gamme la formule a été
revue et elle a été revue sur du temps
de de stephen harper et le comité qui
est qui qui a travaillé la tuque refait
la formule passée mais de l'alberta
lorsque ça a été c'est un monsieur au
grain qu'il présidait donc les
albertains qui se sentent vraiment là
complètement et qui trouve que c'est
tout à fait je crois quand même que en
plus c'est réviser régulièrement il ya
un comité permanent qui est chargé de
revoir cette cette formule-là de la
péréquation une ce qui se passe c'est
que finalement les albertains leur grand
problème c'est que malgré tout malgré
leur leurs déboires des dernières années
à cause du pétrole y restent riches en
votes péréquation pour la même raison
que bill gates sera soit pas d'être
social ces salaires un peu drôle à dire
mais c'est c'est que en fait ils disent
on reste c'est pas que la formule était
juste qu'ils ont plus de contribuables
qui sont aisés
et si on prenait un contribuable au
québec qui gagne 100 mille dollars et un
autre un autre en alberta il
contribuerait de la même façon c'est
juste qu'il y en a plus en alberta
madeleine conclusion je pense aussi
qu'il veut essayer de refus menthe et
son show cure souci partie les contesté
a même son caucus
le dernier incident en lice à propos
d'un souper qu'il a eu avec de ses
proches conseillers et il n'avait pas
respecté la distanciation physique de 2
m donc là il a dû s'excuser pour ça
aujourd'hui mais en fin de semaine il ya
des membres de son caucus des députés
ministres et qu'ils y ont dit excusez
vous donc on est on voit que dans son
propre caucus il est temps en perte de
légitimité
donc les cèdres cimenté tous avec des
idées qui font l'unanimité
merci
coup à vous trois bonne soirée à
pourvoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d
[Musique]